the jurogan experience i have played on
this podcast multiple times you uh
shooting pigs out of a helicopter
they're so beautiful
it's talking about samurai but it's it's
a crazy thing that like people that
don't understand will look at that and
go this is horrible this is awful it's
like you don't understand invasive
species you don't understand the fact
that this actually has to be done and if
you're a person that likes to eat
vegetables guess what they're going to
eat them all they're going to destroy
them all like they they need to do
something about these animals and
there's no way you can stop them from
breeding there's millions of pigs in
texas alone tens of millions yeah if i
may put the definitive comment on that
yeah please do
if you have a problem
with killing pigs from a helicopter
you're an idiot and let me help fix you
because raw edits at some point in life
because we don't know nothing there's
ignorance and i've been ignorant i'm
currently ignorant on how to weld i need
to learn that but i admit my ignorance
so that i don't [ __ ] up a weld i get a
guy who's not ignorant about welding so
let me fix the ignorant out there and
see if i can't weld some intelligence
into their otherwise craving mind for
information
when we kill pigs from a helicopter it
benefits the environment because they
destroy the environment they erode
everything and it causes devastation to
waterways and riverine habitat in just
every habitat so we're saving the
environment so shut up we're saving
agriculture because they destroy tens of
millions of dollars of agriculture every
year so we're saving hours i think
that's just in texas yeah
just texas not to mention california
yeah mississippi
so when we when we kill pigs from a
helicopter we have created an industry
that i legalized before i called then
governor perry and then
attorney general greg abbott it was the
idea
the helicopter thing yeah it was against
the law you couldn't pay a helicopter
pilot to shoot pigs only government
agents were allowed to do it in texas i
know that sounds like a new york law but
it was in texas and when the my buddy
johnson said no you can't pay me for gas
i go well it's got to be expensive the
helicopter cross pilot collateralization
the
you i can't pay you in the game warden
go i hope you're not uh paying him to do
that i go well who are you
how could you possibly think you have
the authority to determine whether i pay
for the gas in a helicopter as i go up
and shoot pigs where do you that's the
law
so the law was you couldn't pay for it
you couldn't pay for it why is it like a
process don't start asking don't ask why
right because why isn't hillary in
prison i mean why isn't she that's my
point the why question is is
if eternal anyhow so i called governor
perry and i said rick
you've got to be kidding me because
everybody knows that wild hogs in texas
texas are an absolute scourge of a
liability you're craving systems by
which we can reduce the population and
then you make the most effective
solution illegal he goes well i had no
idea like well the guitar player will
help now i need to call greg abbott so
on the hunt was kris kobach who happens
to be a constitutional attorney really a
wise one a really super one right up
there with cruz and so we he googled the
laws and he rewrote them at the camp
at the helicopter camp we're slamming
hogs from the helicopter we're saving
farmers money we're saving the
environment we're saving wildlife
because hogs kill everything they can
finally they run into whether it's eggs
or fawns and they're delicious and and
pigs are delicious that's why we created
hogs for a cause charity where we pick
up the dead hogs we process this organic
pork and we feed soup kitchens and
homeless shelters so don't you see it's
wind win win win everything is good
there's nothing bad about it well it's
not sport well then you share with me
your last helicopter hog hunt where you
hit the pigs every time from a moving
helicopter and an erratically running
hog shut the [ __ ] up anyhow so after we
called abbott and and perry and kris
kobach these guys are attorneys and i
don't hold it against them uh they
rewrote it
two weeks later it was legal and here's
the next win we created an enormous new
industry that is generating tens of
millions of dollars for travel hotels
groceries ammo sporting goods
taxidermist ice beer guides outfitters
helicopter owners so it's win win win
win so i'll go back to my opening
statement if you're against this
completely conclusively definitively win
situation for everything you're an idiot
now take the information i just shared
with you and try to eliminate your
idiocy